a short time ago a russian soyuz capsule
landed in kazakhstan bringing two
cosmonauts and an astronaut home from
the international space station nasa's
mark vandehei spent
355 days in space longer than any other
american in a single mission
15 countries are part of the iss but the
u.s and russia are its biggest
stakeholders relations between the two
nations are unraveling here on earth
because of ukraine but mark strossman
shows us it's still business as usual in
orbit for now
station this is houston are you ready
for the event floating above all the
hostility on earth
russian cosmonaut anton shkaplerov
handed over command of the iss tuesday
to american astronaut tom marshburn are
they aware of what's going on on earth
absolutely
but the teams are professional the
astronauts and cosmonauts are some of
the most professional groups you'll ever
see we have ignition and lifts off for
two decades and counting russians and
americans have lived and worked together
in space by design the iss has been the
interdependent space station that
russian segment provides all propulsion
controlling the altitude of the iss the
u.s segment controls its orientation and
provides satellite communications and
solar power cosmonauts and astronauts
operate their respective sides they need
each other to keep the iss alive even in
moments of diplomatic crisis like
ukraine we have our problems with
president putin
on earth if he pulled the plug on this
tomorrow would the whole thing be at
risk if they abandoned the space station
we'd manage we'd figure it out
but we don't anticipate that it survived
all these years it's not going to stop
now but just last month dmitry rogozin
the head of russia's space agency
implied the russians might abandon ship
he demanded iss partner nations lift
their sanctions tweeting who will save
the iss from an uncontrolled de-orbit
and fall into the united states or
europe it's showing off for
you know an audience of one meaning
vladimir putin scott kelly commanded the
iss for three missions if putin pulls
out could the americans alone make it
work it wouldn't be easy um
is it impossible i would say no i think
nasa's proven that they're capable of
doing some pretty
amazing things
another worry in u.s russia tensions the
u.s wants to prolong the life of the
space station to 2030. russia has yet to
commit past 2024.
for cbs morning's mark strassman atlanta